guardate eccolo
oggi scapperemo da un po mi long l'ex
nuovissimo gioco guardate questa eclissi
mistificante quello che si usa nella
lingua dei denti evidenti anche nei moli
un nuovissimo baffo oggi scoperto da
bobby non mente non riesco a stare anche
chi si vede fortemente anti ultima prima
di tutto dai telefoni presi poco
qualcosa mangiare qualcosa da bere la
storia un bel mi piace e iniziamo quarto
abbiamo anche la torcia la torcia
sembra bellissima questa mappa quindi
dove siamo e tipo e lo stesso la
fabbrica che c'è bisogno
e lo stesso la fabbrica di aghi marchi
ma questa volta sembra la fabbrica però
è successo qualcosa
se c'è un 4 fiume di lava cosa che fai
luoghi del gran fuck off attaccare
ma c'è il grappa possiamo prenderlo
no non lo fa prendere ancora forse prima
dobbiamo superare qualche dei quali sono
del 50 non c'è un pupazzo di hacker
si può prendere non si può prendere
vediamo cos'altro cè altri pupazzi di
archi vuoti io adoro esplorare le nuove
mappe e ovviamente se volete che
giochiamo a nuove mappe di aghi o anche
come frey time lasciate un bel mi piace
questo misero aggiunge 5 mila mi piace
ma un'altra nuova mappa non si può
passare da queste poche ma ecco perché
simbolo perché siate un'acqua quasi
religiosamente allora forse l'unica via
e saltare qui su questa loro abbiamo
superare il fiume di lava
qualcosa laggiù spiaccicato meglio
scoprirlo dopo le non viene cancellato
economy non blacks lì che sono in
ritardo era gigante tappa bellissima
cioè bella nel senso è bella ma un po
inquietante per essere carina dai miei
aspettami allora di quadro si può
passare prima cosa è successo qua c'è un
altro fiume di lava che dobbiamo
attraversare l'aspetta qua c'è la mano
di a chi no non riesco a stare qua
guarda lì c'è la mano di mami long l'ex
che tiene anche i vaghi così è proprio
come nel trailer abbiamo visto del gioco
poppy playtime due se non lo avete visto
vi lascio la scheda qua ho qua e dopo
questo video andate a vederlo preso in
reagiamo al trailer e abbiamo una
reazione
ed è bellissimo il trailer qui è
successo qualcosa sono cadute delle sedi
e questa è la reception
ecco la mano di mammella un blacks lo
vedete è gigante attenta a non cadere
come non detto
[Applauso]
sta arrivando costerà quel rumore ma lì
c'è una macchina che sta attraversando
il primo mare
guardate guarda di nuovo dove c'era la
macchina ciao dove sei no non sono
ancora passato a
mi ha sciolto la lava io volevo andare
da un bambino blacks ma non mi fa andare
secondo voi fa più paura chi si missino
ma milan blacks secondo me il bobby long
list non lo so sembra carina sorridendo
mi sembrava betti spaghetti sciopero
paura però dobbiamo ancora a vederla nel
gioco perché può essere che nel gioco
magari nel gioco di prenderti stridono
con le braccia che sia un sacco di
braccia un polpo ok consiglio botanico
serenità ciao ciao ciao
no vabbè
perché l'intero sfracellata perché se la
schiappa enti chi parla biosfera cellino
no
no no sedicenti cosa che poi l'affondo
accantonate di salire sulla macchina è
ok appena arrivata al volo sulla
macchina in fondo ho detto no
mister mi dovessi arrivo
[Musica]
questa è la bambola poppi
coppi vuole giocare si iscriva davvero
guarda il punto queste sono le mani di
bonn milo blacks sono giganti mobil home
next è molto più grande di aki luoghi
almeno da quello che si misero al
trailer mobil home l'ex prende anche
qualche in mano e la mano e gigantesca
attenta qui perché questa porta scendere
di si chiude all'improvviso quindi
potremmo essere affettati ok passa prima
te lo vediamo creare tali si sfracella
no
e qua guarda un grande
tendo la mano e stava aprendo la porta è
successo qualcosa di strano in questo
capitolo di poppi playtime smaghi
qualcuno è stato sfracellato c'è del
sangue naso anche la torcia
iniziano le cose paurose di sottofondi
sfondo li c'e chi si mise e con i denti
di fuori qui con l'arrivo di fuori
che paura credo che chi sia stato solo
salvato quasi un altro giocatore per che
cosa la torcia come noi a proposito
[Musica]
guardate chi si mistifica ottico i denti
anche nella che dovrà mandare da questa
parte
qua c'è anche il braccio di chi si
missive di questa è la mano di chi sia
in rotante se siete bellissimo questo
capitolo fatto benissimo questa volta la
d'oro e a proposito di cose però se
volevo ringraziarvi perché in tantissimi
avete preso il mio nuovissimo libro
stormo rosa con la rivista ieri mi
scrivete ogni giorno su internet sta
piacendo tantissimo in tantissimi dovete
zaffini sotto del libro potete
accumulare i punti coraggio proprio come
una storia solito gioco nella serata
proprio lettera attivo potete accumulare
i punti coraggio e alla fine scoprirà
che ha quale profilo appartenete
esistono varie storie paurose potete
mettere a prova il vostro calcio quindi
se non ce l'avete ancora andate a
prendere poi iscrivetevi se lo vede
presto guarda magari quasi 1 scorciatoie
non dobbiamo entrare vicine labbra
no mi ha morso di siti kiss kiss lissi
si spiccicato dove in un dente
mi sa che non c'è altra soluzione
dobbiamo per forza entrare nella bocca
di sensi visti perché qua non può
passare la luce il trenino aspetta qui
però non può passare chi no non tirano
dentro toccare picchi di cosa si muove
potete correre guarda si fa così denso
batte staccata sfracellata prima non ti
no non ci prova con questo brano i denti
di un serpente sì è vero forse sono
anche delle noti non ci credo che stiamo
andando nella bocca di questi vizi cosa
ci aspetterà
vedremo che cosa ha mangiato
ma
che sa già che ci sei tu siamo ancora
sulla lingua aiutando a me entrare
l'attenzione non entrare mai roma
guardate la gola di chi simili o strade
armato è pieno di venti ovunque
allora come hai fatto a passare è
saltato no devi andare piano piano ed
evitare tra che cos'è questo un rullo
nullo percorrere di lino pedroni ha
mangiato anche la fabbrica dei
giocattoli
wang il ferro attenzione qui c'è
qualcosa di un liquido verde c'è scritto
di non entrare in
un partito dove stiamo amico io sono
caduto
stiamo ragionando l'errore di promesse
certo che è strano che casey mi si è
fatta così se ha mangiato dove loro
fabbrica ci sono pezzi di chi si missing
you agip da siamo infatti diverse no no
io sono alla fine di quel tunnel hanno
sei riuscito a passare non so dove sono
no non capisco tocca andare a giocare
più avanti ok ma tutto vestito riferito
alla sinistra a sinistra che è peggio di
noi hd la testa a posto di saltare non
va bene
i moniti che tenete abbiamo detto no
milan piace più attento salta nostro
gelato
chiti è sfracellato
difficilissimo uscire questa mappa però
è bellissima ma forse non dobbiamo
passare di qua magari scopriamo che c'è
un passaggio più facile fini dovremmo
portare qua sicuramente ci sono quasi
riuscito guarda dai quei
no abbiamo fatto
eco vitale ce la farà vengo sono illuso
fate il tifo pur vitale noto
il nero dai evita di oggi dai l'ultimo
ce l'hai fatta è
attento nell'articolata etm super
difficile come si fa a passare qua non
mi fa passare a dire che abbiamo
sbagliato strada no
sì io sono passato no vabbè ragazzi
tutto perché va a me non fa passare a
vita restio meno
possibile devo tornare indietro a
trovare un'altra strada proviamo noi
possiamo farcela ma devo attraversare
romani
nuovo
ok ragazzi ha dovuto comprare uno slip
stage perché non so perché non mi faceva
può stare qua vi fa dobbiamo andare ora
dove stiamo aspetta ma io guardate ho
fatto lo scoop stage dell'acqua perché
non mi faceva passare non so perché ed
acqua stanno uscendo delle scatole
quindi siamo nella fabbrica negli
ragazzo dietro che
adesso ci sta trafficando di qua ma io
sento con gli all orario un po che cosa
sei qua a proprio è una freccia rossa
credo che dobbiamo andare ma è
sicuramente alcuni di questi pannelli si
no
cominciamo dai iniziato a sfracellarsi
un po
io provo andare qua nel frattempo
non sono un giocattolo e va bene andiamo
facciamo la nostra prova qua
ok
netta perché puro bel gesto
dopo vero abitare strage la dritto
dritto primo che poi e poi non lo so
trovo questo nome
di metti come dritto dalla tomba di totò
dimenticata
quindi destra sinistra dritto dritto
e poi sono forti poi quando sapere
destra e poi 3
noi propria formazione
riproviamo destra si
chiama cella perché non se ne ricorda
anita adesso destra mi avevi detto che
poi non mi ricordo visto che va dritto
dritto dritto ok
bravi fatto allora guarda che cosa
nell'altra parte della fabbrica
di poi non si può andare
lo stesso cibo chi
no non c'è niente
qualcuno si è sfracellato anche li vedi
leva che i disagi
quasi ha scritto di non entrare entriamo
di aver detto cose che sono le mani di
chi si mise i laser va beh vediamo prima
lingua dolce di no magari c'è qualcosa
di andiamo ci sono due strade sia questa
che quella strada prendiamo ho preso
questa dei laser che io provo andare qua
ok riproviamo non nel frattempo facci
sapere cosa c'è in quella dei lattari
sacchi e qui però non si può andare
avanti perchè c'è un bottone da premere
forza sarà la cosiddetta di lottare per
azionare qua la fabbrica e dov'è il
bottone però non vedo quindi in che cosa
vedi doveste allora io sono sono
riuscito ad alzare in un sotterraneo e
c'è una specie di trenino
13 nisi arrabbiato con i pacchi dentro
io invece sono vengono al rullo
trasportatore di giornata davvero
questa sembra sembra che i pacchi
abbiano scavato una via d'uscita che
stiano scappando i tranesi
reincontreremo
pericoloso perché cadono i pacchi nostra
giornata e io questo continuando andare
dentro questo ruolo toccati vada un po
più veloce
mi sa che la via d'uscita l'ho trovata
io
pronto davvero
beh in effetti mi sembra che sto
tornando a noi un altro mattone
devo rifare queste traffico che sono in
una specie di posto bellissimo super
colorato adesso arrivo e ti raggiungo se
si decide di fare quella cosa no la
propria che ci aspetta non potete
constatarlo per forza da rifare questo
tenuto la causa di rifare vediamo se me
lo ricordo io non ci aiuta dai dati
sinistra vero
qualcuno si è solo parlato l'altro
destra e pretora
arrivati ragionamento in qualcosa di
concreto presto andiamo a raggiungiamo
vitale o di pizza poi o trappola con
quella strada lì ma questa volta logica
stop e invece si dice che scava stata si
creda ha
raggiunto giusto guardate che se messi
malissimo e a bocca aperta la sotto
quindi se non ci fossero le grate e poi
finiremo dentro la bara di chi si
distingue questo quello che dicevo che
tutto triste guardo girati
triste carico quando con i pacchi
dove sarà vitale avanti avanti benissimo
questa fabbri feriti questo caso però
deve stare attenta che i pacchi di colpi
che non ti colpiscono insomma ok a testa
salta mai
wow e gigante questa sarà una bellissima
adoro troppo questo mappa è stupenda
isola o se un'altra area della fabbrica
sembra l'aria del trailer di poppi plate
vi ricordate che in questo punto qua
tipo abbiamo visto un altro gioco era
tipo un bruco e poi dopo abbiamo visto
un altro anche i wacky verde noi sarebbe
bellissimo un parco nemica cosa bisogna
stare attenti a non cadere qui perché si
cade nel buio è chiaro piano piano anche
vitale non è caduta è
stato bravo
questo morto sfracellato wow ad ora
troppo questo patto che altri laser
miano
ok sta da
e verso la parrucca e ora questo è più
compiuti da dove cominciare anno ecco
allora avviso il trucco per superare
latere passare dalla parte più bassa e
poi nella parte più
melena mani legate qua ce l'ha fatta
davvero se è passata sotto è davvero poi
fatto bene la parte più alta sempre
stato proprio sotto e anche passino
figlio no dai vita e poi farcela po
difficile così sfracellato terra che
siete
bene
attento però potrà ipotesi farà cadere
giù ok
le mani di lima milon l'ex sono giganti
o posso salire sulle mani e figlio sono
enormi ha conosciuto e continua milan
blacks come dite come ha detto vitale e
una stritola trincee aspettiamo evitare
che sta continuano a parlarsi subito
vero nome è arrivato e ora cosa ci
aspetta in eccesso so they can add era
troppo questa mappa vorrei che non
finisse mai
ma non si può andare questi sembrano dei
lego
posso scrivere passato spero che con un
altro altrimenti dovremmo rimanere quale
la fabbrica per sempre attenti a non
cadere su quel liquido verde
o no non c'è più nessun treno come
facciamo andersen in alcuna vediamo se
ne passa un altro si è scritto che sta
arrivando dove va bene attento a non
farti spiaccicare dal treno però stare
sulle scatole e se fossimo piedi no
forse è meglio di no dai 31 gradi la
tiriamo quale stiamo aspettando sarà
questo tour erano purtroppo il 3 non
basta forse dobbiamo tornare indietro
per mere qualche pulsante
ok come facciamo salire come facciamo
e non ci ha mai fatto salire ma lavoro
applicabili malattie quali po di polo
guarda eccolo da qui sali ok riuscì però
no ma se una schiappa sai
la prova provata cirino groccia
no
no ragazze si sa bene dove siamo ok
ferma essere mancata bene lo stesso sei
mesi e propri profitti fresco vero
mannaggia difficilissima salire ok il
treno il money league io sono seduto
comodamente sopra anch'io come possa
darmi copra che differenza da regista
che rimango qua gli anni sessanta però è
meglio che non mi muovo altrimenti mi
sembra se potrebbe essere solo
dove stiamo andando
ma che bello essere con modelli a questo
rumore non lo so è successo qualcosa non
mi dire che la spunta fuori anche ma
teniamoci pronti c'è una mano ma milan
blacks tube
per uscire mi ha preso mi ha colpito ma
no quindi sei morto la soluzione
migliore è quella che fa tutto maria
sopra quindi le mani con è appreso che
qualcosa è riuscito a passare io invece
non mi è sfracellato ma meno blacks no
quindi veramente la soluzione era come
sono rimandarci creazione di durata
adesso devo aspettare l'altro treno dai
vi sarete aspettiamo mi raccomando non
metterti in alto perché di roma milan ex
buttafuori
ecco perché dovremmo ok mentre
aspettiamo vitale che star wars obrero
con il trenino che stando morì a nessuno
vediamo un po che cosa si è quasi
interessante e soprattutto che cosa
dobbiamo fare qua è molto silenzioso il
treno in ritardo non fate come non parla
e che sta portando ad esso sono tre
minuti mommy docs
o no che succede a
aiuto forse meglio aspettare vitale
avete visto invece l'affare sta per
arrivare ma milan blacks dai vita e
brighi ma è solo salta l'euro sta
arrivando e l'abbinamento io da piccola
ultrà mano di uomini blacks e con la
faccia di bambino resta
eccolo
è molto inquietante qua così adesso vai
precari da un po no ho paura
e poi proprio qui dove 69 eccomi qui
vicino c'è scritto k
però alla freccia dice di piantare
d'amore qui va bene andiamo poi vediamo
ma anche a te lo schermo si spegne
azioni
già mangiato sono riusciti a scappare ho
vinto il premio us che ci sono luci più
scappa ci credo
wow siamo riusciti a tappare della
fabbrica ormai
una forma spetta qui c'è un cartone con
comunque delle cose dentro guardavamo
c'è di vaghi qui che con un punto
interrogativo sulla testa
guarda gli uomini punto interrogativo
sulla testa è cosa si fa vivo anche
qualche sapete
sono soltanto degli umani quindi ma mila
onesta presa di maghi e l'ha buttato
quante wow è stata bellissima queste
scritto un primo voto di todi e chi e
giochi e poi io voto gli da tre o
quattro cartellini qui cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video certo non mi
piace il riscatto su per le preferite
ciao